and i have a question now now go for it
i thought something like
uh do you have any specific openings or
blitz and bullets
yeah oh really i i have so many
um give me e4 d4 just just choose your
choose your poison okay first differ
d4 okay so one one great opening for
bullets
um i i posted this in a youtube video
i'm curious if you've seen it but
there's a trap in the england gambits
england i have heard and probably have
seen but
e5 so what would you do
someone played like in blitz or bullet
e5 but
i used to take on e5 you take and maybe
we can play this out i'll play bishop c5
oh well okay so i'll do with white let
me just
flip the board and treat it like a
bullet game like you have to move
quickly
sure um here we go um
well okay
oh snow worse
can it take break what would you do you
would
you would take the night here right oh
no no
oh my goodness you're actually generous
to give me a take back
[Laughter]
your reaction was like but you assume
it's just a blunder like you you'd
like but that's that's so nice to um
to offer a take back
and you ruined my trickery with kindness
so e3 obviously but like this is it's
amazing for a bullet because
so many people just instinctively take
the knight
and as black in this position the key is
to pre-move knight e7
well because so many people take you
pre-move 97 it looks like a mouse slip
pre-move and um
i have a whole video like diving into
this um
i have a compilation of trapping a lot
of people with this
so oh this sounds like oh okay
i'll try and the amazing thing is
after d4 if you check like the online
databases
this whole line it's it's every single
move is a the top move for white so this
is the most common move
this is most common this is most common
and most people online take the knight
wow and bishop of so like
so like there's a decent likelihood
unfortunately like the video i made
so many people watched it that a lot of
people are aware of it
and maybe they'll be more likely not to
go into it
um but it's just if he does not take any
e7 and just player three i think it's
it's better for white because we have
extra two bones
white will be up a pawn right mm-hmm and
if white takes on c7 there's the same
trap though
um a lot of people will play bishop f4
here
and there you can still get the trap um
you you would have pre-moved 97
and now as black you should pre-move
knight c6
again this is assuming bullet chests if
you pre-move knight c6 imagine what it
takes
knight c6 is played instantly ah steal
and white will maybe take here and then
again you win the queen
i say well so
[Music]
i discovered this maybe a couple months
ago there's another streamer uh gm
derrick
who uh kind of innovated this trap
and he actually trapped nereditsky in
this line as black
whoa so um
yeah so it's a weapon you can add to
your your arsenal for for bullet chess
i i could show you my my weapon against
e42
um you have to maybe
know some more lines but against e4 i
like to play
what's called uh the staffer gambit is
knight takes e5 and knight c6 uh-huh
yes so this is for bullet templates
right
it's tough blitzer bullet i've played it
even in like 10 minutes or 20 minute
games
objectively like if you turn on the
engine uh engine will usually say around
plus two
however it's not easy to play for white
there's a lot of traps white can fall
into
mm-hmm um if maybe we can
i can try and demonstrate like as white
what would you do here maybe we can play
out of
uh okay okay so it's my mono and
all right okay well
probably i would play g3 is very natural
well um
you're playing like one of the best
variations
one of the best which side
this is actually like one of the um
the most recommended variations but i'm
still going to try and trick you
oh well i don't want to get mated
let's take it that's good strategy
oh my bishop's still hanging
okay you played this well you didn't
walk into uh any
any immediate landmines obviously
avoiding the
checkmate on d1
seriously our opponents can't hear us
you did this better than most people uh
who who encountered the opening for the
first time just to show some potential
traps
um there's a lot of people that will
play bishop g5 here
looks very natural and then amazing move
for black knight takes e4
losing the queen but then mating bishop
oh oh this is so pretty
yeah white white's just lost here if
bishop e3
we take in queen h4 g3 we take
and if pawn takes knight we don't take
the bishop
but we can win the queen with bishop f2
yes we have king e2 bishop g4 otherwise
we're
taking so that's one of the
the classic kind of fun traps there's a
lot of players that will
play either d3 and then knight c3
or knight c3 and then d3
even hikaru hikaru played this against
like an amateur player
in one of his like speed run videos
walking into knight g4
and black's already better
because there's no great way to defend
f2 white has to play bishop e3 and then
we
um we win back the pawn with a good
position and both so
we shall send so there's
there's so many traps um i i have
many videos on youtube another common
one is bishop c4
it's just natural development walks into
knight g4
castling and then queen h4
and white's white's just dead
i have a question who invented this
stafford gambit
so it's name i think the first recorded
game
in it was by a player named stafford
but there's there's not so much history
with the opening
and before maybe a few years ago is is
very very rare
but um
i think it's it's been more common
recently
um some of the videos i i have on
stafford have
at least one of them has like close to
two million views
so wow um so people are becoming more
aware of the opening
actually the most popular video i have i
show
there's a line so bishop e2 so what you
played
and then h5 and then a lot of people
will just kind of castle here
and then there's a nice trap knight g4
h3
and queen d6
oh we can't take and if white takes with
the pawn
it's force mate right white has no
defense here
rookie one we check and mate
um so the the video i posted i i trapped
three people in like the same day
and if g3 which a lot of people play
that we just take on g3 and we meet
wow so it seems like innocent variation
when it starts
with black stafford but then it turns
really tough or whatever i mean there's
so there's so many lines which white
just plays naturally
and then just runs into random tactics
i'll show you one more my favorite trap
it's it's one of the deepest traps is
bishop c5
um it's knight c3 bishop d5 white's
gonna play super safe white's gonna play
bishop e2
play h5 and now
what would you think is the safest move
for white like black wants to play
knight g4
after knight g4 what's the safest move
for white so after each five in this
position
if you want to be super safe as white
what do you play
[Music]
well i think uh h3 seems logical
so h3 looks like it stops all the
counter play now there's no more knight
g4
white's pretty much i don't want to say
completely losing but on the verge of
just
almost completely losing oh um after
each three
oh what was seven and it involves like
um
maybe an eight move variation involving
two sacrifices two
minor piece sacrifices in the end
white's king is going to be on d4
d4 it's it's almost completely forcing
so i'll just show you um it like i've
given this to grand masters where like
i'll have them try and calculate the
whole thing
it's not easy but um we start with queen
d4
threatening mate looks natural to castle
and now knight g4
and now we're attacking f2 queen u1
probably if queenie won we play queen e5
and the same idea as earlier g3 doesn't
work
f4 is illegal because it's pinned
uh if takes takes its force mate
bishop takes it it's just a devastating
attack for for black
um so
what a lot of people will do they'll
take the knights
and then we're threatening queen e5 with
force mate
d3 doesn't help so the only way to
prolong the game
is to play g3 and now white wants to
play this and this
so there's only one winning continuation
for black it's really beautiful
so start with queen e5 threatening
maiden one
king g2 now block to move find the only
winning move
i i think i found
rook h2o
unfortunately white can take and if you
check it's stroll maybe oh king chew on
king g1 i know you wanted to like do
this stuff
keep in mind you're already down at
night
uh white's ready to neutralize
everything
so people in chat can try and find it
too i'm sure there's some people who've
seen this
[Music]
i i need i want to find it
oh uh maybe maybe
i i i i thought already i don't know
just broke something um
um bishop f4 f2
so there's a lot of moves being
suggested in chat but
uh yeah good good job to everyone
suggesting bishop f2
so it's a second minor piece sacrifice i
did not see each other
just the idea we're just uh we're
completely destroying the whole king
side
if rook takes then we play queen h5
and there's no rook h1 queen h3 is
unstoppable
uh rook f4 is a try
but then still okay now queen h2 and
this is just crushing rook each one
coming
and you s you said about king d foreign
takes
and then we play rook h2 king e1 was
made in two
so king e3 we take and this is the line
where the king goes to d4
and we're down two minor pieces
but we're completely winning just bishop
e6 we're ready to castle queenside and
engine will give maybe not force mate
but
it's like minus five
well king c4
so it's a beautiful opening especially
for unsuspecting players and
um i've i've trapped like
some very strong players in in this line
and other lines too
so hopefully that gives you guilt
and this was from black as you said
and do you have any other trips oh i've
i have
so like i could spend days upon days
sharing traps but the ones i just show
you are my so my like
i guess two favorite openings
for blitz and bullet just to try and
trap people quickly
especially people who aren't prepared
um i mean if you name an opening
i i i could go like if you wanna if
if there's any opening that you wanna
see traps in um
i mean white side too
trap against queen's gambit oh against
queen's gambit
yes okay i'll i'll share yeah sure i'll
share um
i had mentioned it earlier uh
are you familiar with the name cambridge
springs
i've heard like monster but
yes it's another opening if white just
plays all the natural moves
white's gonna be in trouble and like the
one of the main lines in queen's gambit
is the setup with bishop g5
knight f3 e3 bishop d3
do you play this as white maybe you play
something similar
i play with knight f3 and bishop f4
bishop
okay so maybe a bit different yeah
cambridge springs doesn't quite work
against bishop f4 and we'll see why
um but for the purposes of this let's
just imagine bishop g5
um i'll share one additional kind of
bonus trap
just to start off if knight d7 you can
start with this move
uh this is a pretty famous one it's
called the elephant trap
where it looks like you're losing a pawn
i think i know this yeah so what happens
if white takes
um should i say or wait for chat
um oh there's already one someone in my
chat
knowing the move i think someone's
saying
s takes g5 i'm not sure what s stands
for
maybe he's a different language for
knights
but yeah we we um we lose our queen
temporarily
but then we win back the queen and in
the end we're going to be up
a piece good job people in chat
yes okay so we
like white can't win the pawn here let's
imagine white continues developing
so we play kind of a triangle semi-slav
setup
and then we play queen a5 so have you
seen
this before
um probably probably
yes this is so it's very similar to what
i had shown earlier in the london with
this
um it's basically the same position
earlier
but our bishop is here rather than here
but there's still traps which exist
combining this move
this move and ideas of targeting the
bishop and the knight
so the natural move here for white is
just developing
and now black to move and win material
um
um i i know i know it's as
as you showed me in london
it's like it's like similar i think
oh do you want to draw the play bishop
a3
yes i think the the thing with bishop a3
no
not first move after dtx4
oh okay so you want to take on c4 first
yes
another wish of a3
um i'm actually wondering why that
doesn't working
yes it's it's not the move but i think
bishop a3 there's queen
uh-huh yes but maybe uh
so i'll i'll say we can look into bishop
a3 i'll say the simpler move
is 94. it's a fork we attack the knight
and the bishop
twice
and we're guaranteed to win the pawn
here a lot of people won't see their
bishops attack twice
they'll defend the night and then we win
the bishop this is logical but i was
just trying to find something
genius yes like something extraordinary
i i'm really curious um bishop a3
because idea would be if the queen
defends somehow
we would take and then play this move
oh did you ask me something i'm just
trying to figure out
uh i i might just quickly check the
engine because i i know
this is not the right move but i don't
know why
bishop a3 oh so engine's saying queen b3
and if we take
right i guess there's some issue
i can just get compensation like castle
[Music]
like this is too like complicated
variation
it's complicated yes but it's not
necessary it's a line black wins upon
but doesn't doesn't get a great position
so it's usually better to keep this
bishop and you win a pawn without having
to
um trade off your good bishop
on this i think this is really famous
like txt for the knight for
this trip dtx e4984 yeah yes
and um
i guess white
i forget exact i haven't shown this in
in a while
white will have to defend the bishop
somehow
i guess bishop f4 and then we
we win upon it's actually nicely we keep
initiative we take
imagine white takes takes we fork the
king and bishop knight
t2 only move and we're up upon
and we keep initiative we're either
threatening to trade queens with
ticks on d2 or win the bishop straight
out
so another nice opening trap someone
is as uh saying that you both are great
team
learning so much from you about any uh
any traps from attacking as white in
kings indiana tech
why against kings indiana yeah
oh well you're you're the d4 player
you play like main line but you maybe
play more positionally and less
less trappy lines yes
um i i could share
[Music]
i mean i showed earlier the one trap in
london
um where like we
we allow e5 and then we win the pawn um
so king's indian
assuming we play normal moves is like
this
is this what you play as white yes yes i
do
bishop bishop e2 um uh
black usually plays e5 newcastle
yes knight cc oh you play bishop e3 here
yes
gotcha so only one one trap comes to
mind from this position
there's a lot of theory here i'm sure
there's other traps
uh there's a line where white plays d5
so one of the key lines knight e7
um knight e1
i'm trying to remember i think
i think it's knight d7 anyway i'll get
to the key position
f3 f5 and then if you want to play like
an offbeat line is white
and set up kind of it's a positional
trap is to play g4 here
and it yeah it's it's not the typical
king's indian move to like
push the g pawn on the king's side when
black is trying to attack
um but the points and just to explain
kind of the psychology
when black is playing the king's indian
the main line is bishop d3
or bishop e3 f4 bishop f2 and usually
black tries to get this sum
this pawn chain and the pawn storm
rolling
when you play g4 a lot of players will
still play f4
and try and um like gain space
but this is a trap g upon f4 it's a
it's a very critical mistake
and the reason why is because white
plays h4
and from a very deep strategic
kind of point of view black can never
crack the king side like black has no
attack anymore on the king's side
any time black plays a pawn break if g5
there's h5
if h5 is g5
so black just can't attack and white's
gonna play knight g2 defend the pawn
maneuver the bishop and long term
white's gonna
just attack on the queen side it's a
very good king's union position
so i've seen one position
uh lately that uh here was same
moment then uh that black played f4 and
uh now black does not have any attack on
kickside yes
yes i understand so that's why this g4
is good so the whole point of g4 is to
like kind of slow down black's attack
and and question like what black is
doing next
and if if black takes and we we take and
we play h3 and
again it's kind of hard to attack for
black on the king side